[Music]
this morning on the dish a chef who
rediscovered his roots in Italy and
brought its cuisine back home Nicholas
Stefanelli grew up in Maryland with both
Greek and Italian grandparents and they
all loved to cook he originally
considered a career in the fashion
industry but after a fateful trip to
Italy where he sampled some of the
country's best cuisine he decided to
become a chef his first big hit was
Washington DC's Masseria winner of the
coveted Michelin star then came a
fashiona a restaurant and marketplace at
the city's wharf development and next
year he plans to open the Greek themed
philotimo and Nick Stefanelli good
morning and welcome to the dish how did
I do with all those producers yeah we
have Negroni what are we looking at here
so we brought some of the things that we
have in the restaurant and since we're
going into Thanksgiving some things
that'll be great for the table too we
have risotto with white truffle and
caviar from our truffle and game menu
team's ammonia which is an Italian
crudité roasted Scottish pheasant with
parsley root and mustard fruits
cauliflower with pine nuts and raisins
our linguini with XO sauce which has
been on the menu since we opened
chestnut soup and some cannolis to
finish off you mentioned so we mentioned
all her story you went to Italy the idea
was to be a fashion designer or get into
fashion and then this what was it about
the Italian food that just grabbed you
growing up with my family it was food
was always an integral part of the table
and the experience of living and I never
thought of it as a career and then once
I saw Europe in the late 90s early 2000s
it was just this thing just took over me
and I was just it became a calling I
guess and I came back and what's
culinary school and took it from there
those grandparents meals on Sunday
nights what did what did they serve what
a grandma serve there was a lot of
gardens in the backyard so it was always
a lot of things that were coming out of
there and you know there was one of the
dishes that we serve at the beginning of
Masseria is a tomato sauce that as a kid
I can remember just taking a piece of
bread and swiping the side of the pot to
get that little piece that's drying on
the side so
to mimic that flavor so there's all
these pieces of nostalgia that wonderful
you you open your first restaurant in
2015
correct after working in some pretty big
establishments not too bad you did but
when did you know it was the right time
to make that mark just felt good I think
it was though the end goal was always to
go in open my own space up and it was
just timing I've worked for a lot of
great people had a lot of good mentors
and it was just kind of the natural
progression of leading into taking that
next step one of the great things I love
about chef here is that basically asked
him what which what the latest trends
are in food and he said we don't follow
trends hmm it's not about the trends
it's about it's about classic stuff
classic great stuff and we're taking
things that inspire us and that's the
greatest thing of travel is going to
experience new new techniques new food
whether it's going to Italy or going to
South America or just meeting new people
and you get to see different things that
you can bring into your style of cooking
and kind of do that storytelling it's
such different food in some ways Italian
food Greek food but at the same time
there's got to be something that ties it
together there's a lot of similarities
and then there's a lot of things that
separate them as well so that's going
into telling the other half of my
heritage I think that's the good piece
of it's a new challenge as a cook where
you're learning something new you're
learning new techniques and it's as you
go through the research and go through
and the storytelling and the dishes and
the history of the cuisine and how
things were established and where
they've come from from 200 300 years ago
to where we are today where you know
when you have somebody have one of these
meals whether it's Italian or Greek how
do you want them to walk out what do you
want them to walk away thinking cool I
mean it's the sense of hospitality so
you want people to be taken care of you
want them to be pampered and nurtured
and just kind of feel like they've been
your true guests for the evening as they
leave the restaurant certainly are well
have you sign and ask you if you can
have this meal with anyone past or
present who would it be
I would say my grandparents just because
they've never had the ability to see
where this is went and created to so to
be able to have them come back and see
where we are kind of years later would
be great the influence they started all
thank you chef Nick Stefanelli if you
would like more on him or the dish you
can head to our website at CBS
this morning calm